Beyonce came still looking in the rest
of us me slowly passing away just
completely she like you're like yeah
yeah I mean it was like an alien yes and
I'm like sorry
that's not another example where I
really wanted to know she was there
because I looking in the audience and
you see just like the shape of her weave
it's like if I had spotted that I think
I would have just passed out so I was
happy to know exactly where she was
gonna be and that she was gosh we're so
different I would never want to know
have you ever freaked out on anyone
Tyler like whoa well now that we
mentioning Beyonce at my party recently
one person just one person that was
Nelson Mandela break yeah I got a chance
to sit down and talk to him so not too
up yours is so nice when Oprah does
stuff for you it's bad though when I'm
talking to friends and I start hearing
myself say things and they're like but
it just seems like it's like yeah you
know so just you know it ain't normal
yeah I'm starting to show the lady works
at the bank know Obama Discoverer here's
the first thing we just need to boot it
out of the way okay um we share a love
of the goddess that is Meryl Streep well
I feel like there's anybody does anybody
not have my love and if so they need to
see a doctor
yeah because I am thirty stars away from
her on
[Applause]
I'm pretty bad that is crazy
you just dropped that low I love her I
looked at you so fabulous and you got to
work with her and wrecking the flash she
was a singer first yes she was young
when she whips that out it's it's the
best when we get to see like Mamma Mia
into the world yeah tomates but yeah
actually I did like two scenes with her
my movie I was just too terrified the
whole time to even really like take her
in but then she came to see Jeremy
Hanson which was a show that I was doing
in New York
she came to see you were you so
completely like I added like an extra
voice lesson that week like a new
haircut
like I really like I got prepare because
I got warning but she was coming so I I
would not want to know oh I have to know
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going